about keenan allen speaking of money
absolutely massive game for you tonight
what was the best part of this win
getting the win
yeah for sure man uh we've been on the
other side too many times especially in
my career man just seeing us having the
resiliency to keep fighting uh you've
seen it getting ugly down there uh
coming down the stretch but uh like i
said we just kept fighting man kept
fighting came out on top so that's the
best thing for sure all week you talked
about you personally talked about
getting mike williams more involved in
the offense what you think tonight did
you guys do a good job of that i did i
think we did a great job um i think we
still can get it to him a little bit
more no doubt um obviously you see him
on the end he gets the ball and he's
hungry you see how hungry he is when
nobody gonna stop him scoring that
touchdown and uh that's just a fight he
has in him man he's a big play maker and
he makes big plays now tell me how how
did you guys come together how did you
get man oh man we got a nephew man
how did it happen
talk to him huh man look let me tell you
keenan been about this life for a long
time as far as like i've been watching
him in college then when he got drafted
and he does a lot of great things in the
community so i just want to give woody
may connect with him and we like i say
when coaching the englewood charges he
came out then had a conversation with my
kids and enlighten him and then the
charges blessed us with uniforms so this
is a real interactive thing that we do
with this youth football we like people
like him because he's still connected to
the community so that's how we connect
it up as family that's real snoop what
it is and keenan at this point in your
career what's it like to have a
quarterback like herbert it's amazing
man the guy's running around he's
throwing the ball to everybody he's
making plays man and he's and he's
winning us the game on the back side so
it's amazing to have a guy who can get
it all done
rashaan slater man yeah
you got to talk to me about him this
this is a rookie playing left tackle
he's playing on the all-pro level tell
me your thoughts on him he's a rookie
but if you came to practice and watch
team work you wouldn't know he was a
rookie he works like a uh like a cory
linsley you see corey all the time
getting extra work in you'll see ray
shine over there by himself doing his
own thing getting his work in you don't
see rookies doing that too much
he's so dedicated to his craft and you
can tell it shows up on sundays he
doesn't allow too many sacks nobody to
get to him on that side of the ball so
hats off to rachel no doubt man y'all
real healthy right now too on both sides
of the ball i want to say that i see i
got 33. y'all got nine seven on the end
you know i'm saying y'all looking like
something right now remain healthy y'all
should be a threat yeah we got that's
that's the main thing staying healthy
what has brandon staley done for you
guys because you mentioned earlier when
austin eckler was here you talked about
them finishing yes
instilling that will instilling that
confidence that we got it mm-hmm we we
know we're not we're not what we used to
be we're not we not them and uh you know
he came in he took over that culture and
brought that energy that we would we did
we didn't boys now do you like let me
just discuss it i gotta ask for one yeah
you on your own
side do you like going forward i ain't
thinking about it you ain't even
thinking you're not even thinking about
it it was no it's just automatic yeah
it's like
when i was watching tape too you know we
can give it to herbert
eckler
anybody can get confidence you know
anybody can get the ball in confidence i
like it i'm an officer coordinator so i
love when uh we don't pack a punter
that was a great call
i don't pack punters and stupid you have
got a historic super bowl halftime show
coming up yes sir on this field keaney
you may be playing in the game for all
weekend i hope so that's the intention
how did this whole crew come together
for this halftime come on man this is
west coast at his finest you understand
me dr dre is the general to this
bringing in kendrick lamar eminem mary j
blige and he got to bring his one two
one two the double g it's west coast to
the fullest compton long beach la we're
gonna give it to you like you never seen
it before and i'm thankful to roger
goodell and jay-z and all the people for
letting hip-hop get on that stage at the
halftime show for the first time you got
it great for hip-hop too please believe
it
praise god this is one of the great
nights of my life guys man i appreciate
you guys having me
with you guys i'm happy i got a chance
to meet this dude right here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports